I'm she kills Greg this is villager
squad I've got fresh fit team right here
to build my squad hey I'm excited if I
see you my man my home's only three
that's a guarantee
home
the best quarterback in three years ever
and now moving on to my running bags
now hello for Jamaal Charles man I
believe with your macho's I played
against Jamaal Charles I know me the
rail to deal it's a home there's a lot
of good receivers up here I'm gonna drop
the five like I saved some money on my
quarterback and running back God go with
the best song on the Jerry Rice next I'm
going
now y'all shine took all my money early
man I'm on the retirement bill to share
ameba consistent lockdown for a long
time
I'm so dari Tom could have got there I
wish I could but i'ma say two dollars
for leader Siva dominantly for Patrick
looks a ain't nobody in that fire he did
and I'm gonna leave a tip so I love
Steve Young Joo Montana should be a
Niners fan when I was growing up like
Frank ball tio like this is a maze
enough I don't know how y'all narrowed
it down to this but I appreciate y'all
made it easy but but a time like done
watching in cash rush I want to try
retail but I had a lot of money left so
I had to go to Jerry Rice like it was no
wrong we're going on this list right
here
no cash from homes is nothing he can't
do since he's been playing and healthy
he's a bleep
tomorrow's heaping done everything
caching running everything since he been
in the league elusive here he was a
great player and a great player
Jerry Rice's Jerry Rice he's the goalie
he's done it all that stuff explanatory
chairman first of all he cool he's smart
then when they come to the Bale he hit
him don't want to build yourself is like
he only $2.00 I can shut down the side
of the field for God I do that
I've been Patrick Willis man amazing
career like him the world woman when he
was back there like manatee hey hey good
night is a y'all y'all I see why y'all
back in the Super Bowl now because what
deep it's like our guy now remind me of
this defense of Patrick Willis and
that's the right way to go I'm she
killed Bernie this is Bill just bought